i was originally going to do some other
questions but because i'm going to run
out of time i'm actually going to switch
it and i'm going to jump into the
spoilers stuff first and then come back
which
uh you know um so episode nine is two
hours and 20 minutes uh it's a straight
on movie was at any point did anyone say
well maybe we should just do nine and
ten instead of making it two hours in 20
minutes
it was yeah i was discussing i mean we
we talked about it too i think we just
couldn't find
a good spot to break it because
you know there's almost an hour of
really build up tension
and then it just goes
hard for an hour and then we have our
like 25 minutes of the
coming down coda and so there's not
really it would have just not been a
very satisfying episode
to
to stop it after that first hour and in
our opinion it just would have sort of
petered out and we didn't want a forced
uh force and ending so we just figured
well it'll just be this monster episode
and if you want to pause it uh go you
know
you know go ahead yeah and pick it up
the next night uh did you originally
have any different ending for this
season did it change along the way as
you know what i mean because sometimes
seasons go through big changes yeah uh
and i'm sort of curious if anything
really big changed in this one not that
i remember it's just sticking the
landing is only for for mata knights
such an important part so when we're
breaking a season
that is one of the first things we're
talking about where do we want this
story to end up so we're not
so the ending is always sort of that
goal post even as we're breaking episode
one we know exactly where we're going
and i don't think we've deviated truly
in any season for the finale we've
always
stuck to it and i think i believe it's
the same that the case was the same here
in terms of who makes it you know who
lives or died i think i think um there
was a version where um
dimitri
aka enzo
didn't make it that's true
but um other than that other than that
and then he ended up making it that but
that that's it's radical of a departure
from like the original idea versus what
we ended up with
everything else
the ending of season four is i mean it
sets up a massive thing for next season
basically hawkins is theft you know with
that huge thing in the middle um what
what can you tease people about season
five well i think one reason we're
excited about it like we always have
wanted to do sort of like an empire
strikes back like ending which we tried
to do with four where just like you know
it's it's the sense of
of loss of like like
in in an unusual for us at least season
five is gonna start
pedal to the metal i mean we're not
gonna do the ramp up we're not there's
no time there's no normalcy obviously
once you reach the end of four i mean
it's not like there's gonna be time to
explore our characters
love life and how is steve's dating
going and i mean there's going to be
none of that it's just going to be going
100 miles an hour from the beginning i
mean we have like the opening scene for
five mapped out i don't know if it'll
stay like that but it's pretty wild
so yeah no it's it's going to be it's
going to be intense from beginning to
end with
not so much ramp up how much did you
debate max being the person who was the
fourth victim and all the stuff that
happens with her
uh
you know
i mean we always knew i mean
i can't remember how much the max i mean
we did debate how
what exactly we wanted to do with max
but we knew that she was going to
obviously be putting herself in real
danger
and i think
i'm trying to remember exactly how we
landed on where we did with max but it
was it was pretty early on i believe
that we decided that that's that was
going to be her fate uh you know for for
the end of this season it had it had to
be max
um because she you know she you know she
was targeted yeah um and she had never
rid herself with this curse she was just
kind of putting a band-aid he was using
you know effectively kate bush or music
too
as a as an armor and so you know it was
very early on you know
that that was the plan that she was
going to remove that armor and more or
less
um sacrifice fights herself too back
then in order to give them a chance to
to kill him but both both her and eddie
i mean they're really
you know from the get-go they are
targeted and they're they're both sort
of screwed as a result of that in
circumstance in the case of of eddie so
in some way we see the seasons as i mean
they're both doomed in a way since since
the beginning of the season different
from something like bobber where it's
just a shocker it's like these
characters are sort of hurtling towards
uh disaster from very early on uh in the
season
are we done with seeing russia
we um
as listen
things change things change
it's odd because we did outline you know
we we shut down for six months like
every every show everybody the whole
world shut down for six months so we did
we do have a full outline for it
currently uh russia is not in it
i mean i think i think one of the things
that's exciting about season five is
it's
season four was interesting to us
because everyone was kind of scattered
to the winds that's what was unique
about it but this is about everyone
finally coming back
coming back together coming back to
hawkins hopper back in hawkins top her
back with opening the original group
back together the original group of boys
plus 11 like the og
group and like so there's there's
something interesting to sort of
re-explore some of the
season one dynamics again
uh except on this grander
scale yeah come full circle
um i loved the scene with will in the
car
talking about 11 but he's talking about
himself yeah um it's it's just such a
great scene and i uh what can you tease
about like will
in the future uh in terms of because you
know i really enjoyed what you did oh
good thanks man yeah no i mean noah is
amazing i mean noah just i mean we shot
that scene that was like it's like a
half a day shooting that scene from
getting every angle it was an important
scene to get right we felt but noah was
i thought just incredible in that scene
will's gonna be a big part and focus is
really all i can say of um
of season five and his journey but
you're starting to see
um
you know
this you know he his coming of age
really um which has been
which has been challenging for a number
of reasons
um some of which are supernatural um but
you're starting to see him come into his
own and i also love that scene between
him and charlie him and his brother
jonathan
and his brother being there for him and
i think that reconnecting with his
brother is going to be and again that's
sort of setting up sort of us coming
full circle back to season one and i
think you'll see that with a couple of
the character arcs not just with will
but also with you know steve nancy and
in her relationship with jonathan where
uh
things are not fully resolved we've you
know they the characters have maybe made
steps like in the case of will but that
journey isn't over yet and that's really
all of that is going to play a huge role
uh as we try to wrap this thing up next
season
do you think metallica is ready for the
amount of people that are going to be
listening to master of puppets based on
what happened with kate bush
i hope i think i've heard metallica is
excited
about it um
but i don't know i haven't i haven't
like i haven't i i haven't spoken to the
band or anyone in the band um but
hopefully i i hope it does i we were
talking about this the other day i was
like i wonder if if that's going to
happen for
master of politics
apparently there's a cat that wants to
join this interview
you i mean you can't predict like the
running up the hill the kate bush thing
i mean it's so it's so bizarre and then
i mean i'm not on tick-tock but people
are like oh it's all over tick-tock i
don't even really understand what that
means but it's just bizarre how that
stuff happens and whether it happens
again with another band i don't know
um i mean certainly the type of thing
you're not gonna in season five attempt
to replicate because you know i've
already get asked that question it's
like what song are you
you know
um gonna do in season five like we're
not gonna do that again because if we do
it we'll fail it wasn't you know it
wasn't
it wasn't designed to
happen
yeah it has to be organic it's sort of
like the box office success of top gun
maverick you can't predict it's going to
make a billion dollars it sort of
happens
you know
no and like every phenomenon at netflix
that i can think about you know when
you're talking about squid game and
queen's gambit it's like i mean you just
can't um
force that yeah yeah there's nothing
mathematical or
pre or you know you can't figure it out
i mean studios have been trying to
figure it out forever but and and same
with creatives like oh yeah this is the
formula that works the minute you try to
use that exact same formula it's going
to fail so we won't even attempt it
again it's how it's just it's it's kind
of an unreal
uh or surprising
um by chance we have this other big
musical moment which is uh it's a very
different type of musical moment i guess
with mastermind it is but we had to give
eddie his his big moment there no
completely i i had a blast with it what
can you actually say about the hierarchy
of the upside down what what is you know
what i mean like how much have you
actually pulled back the curtain and how
much is sort of like the is there some
big reveal that you guys have been
holding back for season five
yes the the big reveals remain uh that
were that are coming in season five are
really about the upside down itself
which we only start to hint at you know
there was that moment where we realized
in episode seven this year that it's
frozen in time so that is something that
we obviously we do do a couple more big
reveals in volume two but it's all
related to
uh wechner henry and in his journey but
what we haven't really discussed is is
exactly what the upside down is
where what was that where where vac know
what where henry was when he was found
the mind flare where is that so all of
that is going to be
those are sort of the last big reveals
uh coming in in season five how much did
you debate exactly the final shot of
episode nine like where you really
wanted to end it that came pretty early
i mean we knew we wanted to end with
spores falling in hawkins i don't
remember how early in the process but
pretty early in the process
and we wanted that i mean the shot you
know we like like i said we were very
much inspired by empire strikes back
that ending
where they're you know they're looking
out the the window and so we wanted this
shot we want we knew we wanted to end
with the on the backs of our characters
as they're looking out towards this dark
supernatural
plume that was spitting out these spores
and on all over their town as they're
sort of facing this evil that is
not retreated but
but very much coming in an aggressive
way into their town wanted to hint at
the notion of war
um
and a supernatural war coming to hawken
so i know we have that image really
early we have an amazing concept artist
um who's been with us since season two
michael maher and he drew it up and we
just were
really excited to shoot it and finally
see it come we actually just saw it
finally kind of come together the final
vfx like a week and a half ago or
something like that but the goal the
goal of this one unlike other seasons
like maxine is that sense of
anticipation where you've set up what
the stakes are which is something we
haven't done for other seasons so we've
set the stakes and it's just the
the feeling you always want to try to
get is that empire strikes back feeling
oh my god i'm so excited to see what
happens next and or or fellowship of the
ring as they're just headed off towards
mordor like that
that's the dream that's the hope that's
what you're that's the feeling you want
which we just haven't been able to do
before because generally we really wrap
up the story lines then we go oh but
there's one there's some horror lurking
beneath the surface that the audience
sees that our characters don't
necessarily see in this case our
characters truly see that the horn it's
like how what are they going to do how
are they going to deal with this what is
their journey going to look like and so
those were the two films that we
referenced when we were working on that
last shot
uh you guys have talked about and
netflix has talked about and sean levy
has talked about uh the spin-off um and
i know netflix obviously will be
desperate to get something um and i know
you're not going to tell me what it is i
accept that but i am curious with how
particular you are and how you like to
be involved are you going to be content
to sort of just produce a spin-off or do
you see yourself doing
uh what vince is doing on better call
saul and all of a sudden you know he
gets pulled back in and he's on another
show right yeah i mean we've talked
about that a lot we do talk about the
vince gilligan situation a lot um no i
mean i mean ultimately the hope is to
you know pass the baton to
um somebody else
um you know because by the time we're
done with this it's going to have been
god it's going to be almost have been 10
years
it's going to be in my you know more or
less my entire 30s
and so
it would be another you know
five to ten year
uh commitment on this thing and i don't
think you can go half in
you know there's not a version of and i
was telling this to somebody else
there's not really a great version of us
say doing a pilot and then abandoning it
it's like no no you're in the editing
room every day you're in color you're in
sound you're all in or not so
what ross and i really are interested in
is you know we've been developing the
story which we haven't told anybody yet
so i don't even know if anyone's gonna
like it i we're very excited about it
that's all i know but netflix has been
cool they haven't been pressuring us
very much honestly about it i mean
they've been they're they're very
shockingly patient with me and ross
keep in mind they still have another
season to get out of you so i don't
think they're concerned about the
spin-off until you're done with season
five as soon as you turn in season five
it's game on maybe yeah the pressure is
beginning to mount i start to get more
text about it especially as we've been
talking about in the press you know
we're talking about in the press and
they don't know it uh what the idea is
and that's i think maybe not driving
them crazy in enough and like not
they're not like upset but they're just
they want to know what it is finn
wolfhard i think i have said this and
the press knows what it is only because
he guessed it so if you actually
correctly guess it i'll tell you but
he's the only one
um
can i do like a 30-minute interview of
just guesses
he wasn't like it wasn't like him
machine gunning is it this is it this is
it this he just goes
is it that and then i and i think the
only way he could do that is hey he's a
really smart kid he's a really creative
kid and he just knows me and ross too
well he's known as he knows what our
sensibilities are and what we're
interested in so anyway he i don't know
how he figured it but you know we were
honestly working on it right before this
interview so i think you know because we
are done with where you know we're done
with four obviously since it's coming
out tonight i don't i don't actually
believe i don't believe you i'm sure
you're going to tweak a shot that's
going to be going out you know
um it was 20 shots got changed
yeah so if you if you watch it
if
the people who watch it stay up tonight
and watch it does it it'll be it'll be
different tomorrow i'm told tomorrow
either morning or afternoon it will be a
little different yeah i'm not not
editing editing it's just a visual stuff
it's it's no it's totally it's the fx
show
no no no it's not like people think
we're like changing the edit i'm like no
no you can't no no completely
because i'm almost out of time i do want
to touch on
when do you see yourself
filming season five do you have like a
start date in mind um you know it's it's
what we're the plan is to be perfectly
honest is math we're going to take a
little uh vacation in july and then
we're going to come back i know that the
room the writers room is going to start
uh in on in that first week of august
and at that point we're going to sort of
set settle on on some dates uh because
we have actors uh asking us every day so
we're going to settle on some dates and
figure that out but um yeah i think the
only thing we want maybe this year is to
it was really nice to have all the
scripts written
um
so we that is a goal i don't know if
we're going to be able to achieve it or
not which is to have all scripts written
before we begin production
um it's the final season it's incredibly
important we get the narrative and the
story right and we don't want to be
doing what we're typically doing when
we're writing stranger things which is
you know laying down track as the train
is
flying listen i'm going to say to you as
a fan of the series i thought that this
season was so good and i know it's a
result of having all the scripts
it helped yeah it definitely helped it
it made it made a difference so we i
mean yeah like in in an additional time
we never have time to go back when you
turn in a script and it's it's shooting
the next uh it's wild i mean there's
something really exhilarating about that
i do
i do find that pressure
really funny like actually having that
gun to her head had made has made me and
ross better more creative writers
but that being said i think we can still
move relatively fast and
get
get it all down on paper so we can look
at it as a whole because never before
has it been important to get the whole
right yeah um because we have to as ross
was saying every story line has to be
resolved um whether it's satisfying or
not to people i don't know but it needs
to be satisfying to us it needs to you
know the actors need to be one of the
actors and we want to give the
characters their moments and and allow
you know a lot of these characters have
been evolving over the course of
you know these four seasons well and so
it'll be the fifth five seasons of them
and so we want to make sure that they
all land in a in a way that we all feel
good about we do feel good about the
ending we feel like we do feel like we
got the last 20 minutes
they're kind of locked in like i told
you sticking the landing is still that
was like the biggest relief it was like
i was like okay i think this ending is
not i'm not super insecure i'm insecure
about a lot of things but no i feel like
the ending feels good yeah i hope it'll
feel right we'll see definitely no
pressure to end this series right no i'm
sure you're not feeling anything no no
pressure at all no no no not at all all
right so let me ask you a few quick
things about season five do you think
it's gonna be nine episodes eight
episodes ten do you even know
no well we thought this season you know
that's why i hate today because we
thought it was gonna season four was
gonna be eight seasons and they were
gonna be regular length
um so if you had interviewed us before
four that's what i would have said i
think we're aiming for eight again we
don't want it to be 13 hours we're
aiming for more like 10 hours or
something i think it's gonna be longer
than say a season one because we just
have so much to wrap up but i don't
think it's going to be
as long as season four but
do not hold me to that because but again
it'll help that it can speed you know
this season for instance it was two
hours before our characters even
realized the monster was killing people
in hawkins so we they know what the
threat is now and so that will help
speed it up so we'll we'll see yeah
exactly so we're almost it's odd that's
where we feel like we're going to lose a
couple hours
in that
ramp up one of the things about season
four is it's just f and massive in terms
of all over the place do you is season
five gonna be like this world like going
outside uh hawkins are you you know like
the way you did in season four or is it
a lot more contained
where it's really about the the the
what's coming up out of hawkins yeah
it's it's in it's it's mostly in hawkins
and a lot and you know there's a lot
obviously in the upside down
which is exciting and also not exciting
because i just i swear half of my life
is spent
looking at spore shots
and just going that sports too big that
sport just flew through the body of our
character
anyway so that's you know i don't want
to think how many hours of my life have
been spent watching sports shots and
will be watching and looking at support
official effect shots so i'm totally
curious in terms of you guys divided the
release because of you know vfx shots
and getting everything done
the first seven episodes and then eight
and nine
going into season five i'm sure netflix
wants to do something similar in terms
of a staggered release and not give them
all at the same time or is it something
that you you know what i mean have you
already started thinking about in the
writing process maybe we want episodes
one through four to be part one and five
through eight to be part two
right i mean it would be i mean listen
we actually haven't gotten into those
discussions with netflix i don't know if
maybe everyone's waiting to see how this
um split happened but yeah you're right
the split resulted yeah it was two
things i mean i mean one of it yeah the
episodes
um yeah i mean really the episodes were
not done weren't gonna all be done by
may and just wanting to get it out as
fast as possible but it was not designed
to split but i like what you're saying
which is if we were to do a split again
write more to the split you know right
which we didn't do this i mean it kind
of we're lucky that seven had
uh that kind of ending with the vector
reveal um
that that was just sort of fortunate it
was just extremely challenging to get
seven episodes out by may i think that
was the most challenging thing we've
ever faced um while making stranger
things
and so if we were to do it again i would
probably make a split earlier like
you're saying and i would i would write
it into the narrative no completely
i personally i uh i've listened i would
love to see all 8 at once but there's
also like people talk about it more when
it's split up
like it's more than the time
yeah like i know for us it's way better
that you guys split it up like we're
able to keep writing about it you know
what you get yeah you know what i mean
it's such a balancing act because i also
like as a consumer i like you know i
fell in love with
tv really sopranos but i was not i was
not watching it real time i was watched
getting the dvds on mail and netflix and
just
just devouring it and so it's such a
balancing act but i like i do enjoy like
what we did this season and that you got
a little
you know get a bit of both worlds and
that you were able to devour a lot of
content and get into the characters and
story but at the same time allow for
discussion
and and all that in between so we'll see
we'll i don't know it's interesting i
think that's the kind of stuff that
we're going to start i think netflix is
open you know we'll you know i'm sure
they'll have thoughts
how much of you guys thought about do
you have a lot of deleted scenes and
cool stuff that has never been seen and
are you purposely saving it for maybe
like an ultimate you know box set that
could come out don't it's so weird we
don't delete
scene i think there's been
um one deleted scene
in season one or two do we have two
deleted scenes remember one from season
one and then one from this season but
they're so boring
it's not like some exciting
uh deleted scene they're just really oh
yeah it was like it was like just a like
it's like a 20-second driving car scene
because usually what we do is the scenes
there's always a reason for the scenes
and so usually rather than cutting
scenes if a scene isn't um it's hurting
the patient or whatever matter i will
just really trim it and tighten it up as
much as we can it's generally what we're
doing we're not right chopping scenes so
there's not some magical backlog of uh
deleted scenes to be there to lots of
deleted lines but not a lot of deleted
scenes are are you thinking though at
all after the show is done about doing
like a big 4k blu-ray box set type thing
is it have you even thought about it
kind of we're honestly think am i
allowed to talk about that
i we're thinking almost the opposite
i want to like a v
and netflix finally agreed i was like i
was like i've been bugging them about
this forever but i want to like a vhs
canon i want a pan and scan version
of uh at least season one i just want to
try it at cannon and scan it we're gonna
play it and put it through a vcr vcr hit
it a couple times put it on netflix at
least
the nerd in me loves it the nostalgic
factor we had our colorists do the
opening scene of season one panda scan
for us it's awesome just for fun and it
was just brought back so many memories
but hopefully we'll do the blu-ray we'll
do the 4k we'll do the beautiful thing
and then we'll do the pan and then
format it for your tv i i do think that
it it pings me with streaming how many
things can be done and they don't do and
like what you're saying is releasing a
vhs version of season one pan and scan
on netflix so it looks like you're
watching a vhs tape like that's cool
like people should be doing more of this
i don't know
and they were like oh it'd be its own it
wouldn't be embedded it would be its own
separate thing like stranger things vhs
for whatever it is
and um anyway i'm excited about we'll
see if it happens they feel like they
finally well now that they're they're
annoyed about us asking so now that
you've we've said it on this interview
they have to do it that's yeah they're
going to be not happy no just kidding
they'll be fine they've already i guess
okay i'm going to ask this uh like dmd
is
obviously like a key source of
inspiration for the series um can you
speak to its influence on the writing
and how writing a season is similar to
crafting a campaign it is similar i mean
it is similar to crafting a campaign
although it's odd i always say it's like
ross and i actually
um we actually our big board game
players did not play a ton of d growing
up it was like because we were early
actually early 90s and 90s kids and it
was like magic the gathering was the
thing
magic the gathering was
our biggest obsession and the first
movie we ever made
was an hour-long match of the gathering
movie i mean it was just us ha you know
hacking at each other with plastic
swords but what i love about d and i've
you know grown to love about it
even more so
is
yeah the the storytelling and the
creativity that's
you know that's involved in it and so
it's
and and and the wealth of amazing
monsters that are involved so it was a
very early idea that we had you know
when we settled on obviously magic
didn't exist and we settled on okay well
it's going to have to be dnd which ross
and i did play just not obsessively
um
and
you know we settled on that and then i
think it was not until we were
a couple scripts into writing season one
that we
realized
well they would call the bad guy the
villain the demogorgon they would name
him after one of the creatures in the
dnd mythology and so that's kind of
ended up
sticking and the idea that the kids are
using this game in order to
explain and understand
the
unexplainable the bizarreness that's
happening around us so i know it's been
we're really glad we kind of
accidentally had them playing not
accidentally but had this opening scene
of them playing d d which is almost as
much an homage to et as anything else
sure
you